- With all of this week's negative news
about the relationship between
the United States and Mexico,
I've been thinking and I
thought I'd try and do something
positive, so here's the plan.
I'm gonna head down to Mexico
City, rent a television studio
and shoot and episode of
our show with the help
of an all Mexican staff, crew,
guests, and studio audience
and we're gonna call it
Conan Without Borders
Made in Mexico.
(applause and cheering)
Yeah.
We're gonna shoot it down
there and then this special
is going to air on Wednesday,
March first and 10:00 pm,
so you can watch what happens there.
(applause and cheering)
I am, I'm really fascinated.
I'm looking forward to
who we're gonna meet,
how it's all gonna work.
- Right, you're basically outsourcing.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
We're outsourcing the show for episode, or
- Right, just for one episode.
- Yeah, well yeah, just for one episode,
but we'll see how it goes, you know.
- [Andy] Oh wow!
- You know, if it really
- Everyone's on their toes.
- If it really gels, maybe
that's where I'm meant to be,
so yeah, so anyway, watch for
that show, I'm excited for it.